hey guys Eric here to show you some
diablo 3 the patch just dropped
yesterday but what I'm really going to
show you in this video is power leveling
power leveling is back kind of like it
was in diablo 2 all you need to do is
join a friends game in master level or
torment level which is the new
difficulties whichever one they can do
the fastest obviously the harder the
difficulty the more XP bonus you'll have
but you should still see the same
results and I'm going to follow my
friend here into the weeping hollows the
weeping hollows has a lot of monster
density and it'll be a good place for us
to showcase the power leveling
you
so this power leveling tactic is
probably not intended so definitely want
to log in and do this if you're
consenting other classes if you didn't
have that witch doctor a wizard or a
monk that you wanted definitely get in
now before Blizzard probably hotfixes
I'm going to add some experience bonus
gear to speed things up just to show you
how much faster it could be technically
I probably should've did this from the
start but anyways here's the cane set
which adds thirty percent experience
bonus as well as a ruby in your helm
that adds another twenty-five percent I
could have had a better Ruby but that's
the one I had a time and as well as my
help fire ring that adds another thirty
five percent grand total with the gear
bonus as well as the bonus experience
from torment I'm getting three hundred
ninety percent bonus experience you can
see how rapidly I'm gaining exp here
with the exp bonus I've only gone
through one area and I'm already level
53 I think that took about 10 to 12
minutes if you don't believe me you can
look at the top right of the screen here
you can actually see the time that where
we started which is about you know 350 I
don't know 353 354 and you know it's
only about 40 340 for now it's been
about you know 10 10 ish 10 to 12
minutes and that's counting me swapping
gear and like moving gear around so I
wouldn't be surprised if you could
actually level up to you know 60 within
less than an hour I would say try it
yourself and I'm sure if your friends
can do torment a higher torment which
would equal to a higher exp bonus it'll
probably be even faster because this is
only torment one we're going to keep
experimenting with different things with
this new patch so stay tuned to gamespot
com for more videos like these and I'll
catch you guys soon with my new monk